one of the things I wanted to accomplish
here is the policies that you both
Implement have a great impact on the
citizens of your individual states um
for years a gallon of gasoline Governor
Newsome in California has been notably
higher in your state than in the State
of Florida that's right here are the
numbers by the way recent numbers the
average cost for a gallon of gas
Nationwide just over
$324 in Florida
$317 in California it is a whopping
$485
so Governor Nome I ask you you've also
sued big oil companies alleging
Executives have deceived the the public
about uh the health of our planet
knowing that it's a polluter if your
lawsuit is successful that would likely
mean higher gas prices even higher gas
prices for everybody here's my question
though could you name right now one
source of energy that you can bring
online in the next 3 to 6 months that
would be as inexpensive for the people
in this country as fossil fuels let me
let me let me let me touch can you can
you think of that energy let me touch on
I'm going to get to your question and
let me touch or the latter part of your
question let give the first part of the
question okay you're absolutely right
since the 1980s Republican
administrations Democratic
administrations uh have experienced
under their uh stewardship experienced
higher gas pric in the state of
California we've been ripped off by Big
Oil we continue to be ripped off by Big
Oil Big Oil now is met a new Foe and
that's the state of California the most
aggressive anti- gouging law in America
more transparency being required at any
time in America and yes we're suing
we're suing the industry responsible for
this climate crisis by the way the same
climate crisis that Ronda santis
celebrated as human human caus who
campaigned for a fracking ban who
campaigned to oppose offshore oil
drilling and then two days after after
he got elected signed an executive order
by the way Nikki Haley add you dead to
WR on this Ron signed an executive order
doubling down saying you're adamantly
opposed to fracking adamantly opposed to
offshore oil drilling you were
celebrated by the Sierra Club for that
action until you weren't once again it
shows the hypocrisy of Ronda santis now
you're running away from climate change
as things have gotten worse hurricanes
wildfires droughts and floods
$179 billion do weather weighted related
disasters and he has no response except
talking points from Big Oil that was
that was that was again just just more
lies but here's the thing California is
the only one that oil companies are
gouging why aren't they doing that to
Georgia or Florida these other states
that have lower gas prices because of
their policies that's why people are
paying more there what Gavin new wants
to do what he's doing in California what
Biden wants to do nationally is
government dictated green energy
policies uh they want want to kneecap uh
fossil fuels and reliable energy we've
already seen what's happened in
California they have rolling blackouts
he actually implemented a mandate to buy
to buy electric vehicles so pretty soon
in California you're not going to be
able to buy a normal car only electric
vehicles and they celebrated that it's
like a great thing couple days later uh
there was a notice from the state
government telling all EV owners do not
plug in your EV because they don't have
enough grid capacity so he is walking
his people into a big time disaster
whats dos the CIA model he wants toose
that nationally he wants to take away
your ability to purchase the car that
you want he wants to kneecap reliable
energy and I he wants to bring these
rolling blackouts all across the United
States of America it doesn't work it's
going to cause huge problems we have
more energy here we can be the dominant
energy producer in the world FL that's
what we're going to Florida is not a big
energy State we have the Marcel ja we
have the west Texas we have all of that
so let's do that no forcing electric
vehicles we got take American Automobile
when we come back we'll continue the
great state red state blue State debate
more with Governor Ronda santz more
Governor Gavin Nome as we continue thank
you for being with us from Alpharetta
[Music]
Georgia hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interview and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else